[Music]  and that's the iphone 5s and 5c now i  bet you're wondering where is that  groundbreaking envelope pushing paradigm  shifting idea you've come to expect from  apple well  it's right here  introducing apple hot sauce  hold on it's available in mild medium  and rim fire  okay well no hold on just one sec we  could we're working on other things i  mean we're working look at apple barso  for instance we all need to be clean  right  no what about scarves  nice and warm apple scarves bird houses  we make apple birdhouses look at them  they're very nice very nice  craftsmanship what about  neck pillows apple neck pillows  we don't know what you want  we don't have any ideas anymore this is  it just tell us what you want it just  right me  we don't know what to do anymore  god come back  come back steve jobs  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i thought the soap looked good